A very big week of news.
Let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 750
and see what is on people's minds.
Starting with our caller from the 7 0 7 area
code caller from 7 07.
What's your name where you're calling from
today?
Hello, it's me, I'm Bart.
Bart calling in from 77.
Yeah, Bart, what's going on?
David, thanks for taking my call.
Been spending months trying to find out when
the coal numbers were hits, and I realized
that finally there was that you had posed
to them a fund on Twitter.
Yes, indeed.
So my first my first my first question was,
can you go ahead and perhaps put them on the
website?
Because maybe a lot of people that aren't
on Twitter that may want to call in.
We've been getting to that Twitter.
Twitter works quite well because sometimes
the time changes and it's much easier to put
a post up, but we'll certainly investigate
that.
To appreciate that.
So I'm on your campaign now.
I joined up.
So what recommended actions do you you make
and others like me?
You know, for the upcoming election, it's
what can we do from California?
California, where a blue state.
What can we do from here?
Now, I've been on phone banks and all that
stuff.
You have any specific recommendations you
can give us from states that are pretty safe
in the blue world for Joe to help in those
other states that may not be quite so supportive?
Well, I would be.
I'm guessing that the the Biden campaign understands
this, but I would be focusing in on the stakes
states likely to make a difference.
There's a lot of good, good models online
about which state is likely to be the deciding
state.
And like so, for example, my state of Massachusetts,
almost no chance that it will be the deciding
state.
So it's not worth putting a lot of time into
phone banking here.
If you look at a state like Michigan, if you
had a state like Wisconsin, other states,
way more likely that they're going to be the
deciding factor.
So I'm I'm guessing that the phone banking
should disproportionately be targeting those
states.
Yeah, in that levitated 28, you know, joint
phone banks for various people in Georgia
and such, I was trying things like that, but
I didn't have specific groups that we should
you might call out for us to join or to link
up with the sites, ActBlue or whatever.
No, I wouldn't have any I certainly wouldn't
have any group recommendations, but I would
go by what the what the Biden campaign is
directing the volunteers to do.
I wouldn't have anything any special insight.
Okay.
And I wanted to tell everybody, you know,
that maybe worried about Joe is that, well,
what I really want to Bernie that to win until
I'm 60, but still a progressive in my in my
world of thinking, I think he's going to bring
along hopefully a very great vise president
candidate, which maybe it's a woman.
I hope so.
And that would allow the whole system to be
maybe give women a better chance even to get
to the presidency in the future.
So I just wanted to throw that out as it is.
It's fair, in my view, substantially better
than even Joe himself.
All right, Bart.
Very good.
Great to hear from you.
Appreciate the phone call and all.
Very, very well said.